[Musique]
c'est tellement de bazar que je sais
même plus où ranger tout ça aujourd'hui
on va parler du mail 20 de huawei je
vous ai déjà parlé du match d'impro
l'inquiétante parle un peu du matin le
médecin qui est là parce que c'est un
smartphone que je trouve vraiment super
intéressant je pense qu'il est un petit
peu effacée par le maître 20 pro qui est
là forcément quand vous avez tout dit le
plus haut de gamme à 200 euros d'écart
vous oubliez tête un petit peu le
deuxième le nec va néanmoins sommer
devant il est franchement franchement
franchement hyper intéressant alors ce
qu'on va faire aujourd'hui on va
regarder le maïs 20 on va regarder un
peu ce qui peut nous apporter en termes
de photos de vidéos d'écran tout ça tout
ça on va regarder un peu par rapport au
may 20 pro comment il si tu vas pas à
les comparer en face à face parce que ce
sont pas les mêmes produits
on va surtout comparé face au wa one + 6
t qui est juste là ça va permettre un
petit peu de voir un peu ce qu'il en
dépit ci fait si là on sent un peu parce
que je veux montrer très très très très
rapidement ce que j'ai reçu c'est le
trek rx4 de crosse cole qui est enfin
arrivé alors j'ai pas mal d'accessoires
à la tâche pas mal de trucs donc s'en va
seul à regarder
il perd rapidement semble vous avez
réussi là la trottinette électrique des
chiens ont mis ça c'est cool on va
pouvoir se faire des petites virées avec
andreas l'attestait des pneus
supplémentaires
je ne serais pas du tout qui a déplu
supplémentaires intérieur on a reçu
aussi
alors ça c'est une tare l'eau n'ont même
plus le nine bottes un nein dot s2
shiomi on va se se tester hyper rapide
mais rapidement j'ai reçu ce matin
aussi le réseau fon 2 qui est juste là
donc ça c'est pareil on fait gaffe le
d'ici quelques jours on va se tester
on va regarder ça parce qu'on les hait
vachement dans les smartphones de gaming
en ce moment si vous avez suivi
on a le rock fun avec tous les
accessoires qui sont là aussi c'est
sortir une une vidéo hyper hyper
rapidement pour vous en parler donc une
grosse actu ya plein de trucs
il ya plein de produits non il faut que
je vous parle derrière il faudrait des
journées de 48 heures pour essayer
d'avancer suffisamment vite et puis de
faire tout le contenu bon vous inquiétez
pas on va y arriver
step by step sa part pas avoir à sortir
pour l'heure on parle du mail 20 on va
se faire un vrai faux culs dessus on va
regarder
vous me direz vous en commentaire ce que
vous en pensez huawei c'est à dire une
vraie belle accélération vous avez en
parallèle le mail
prot qui est aussi une vraie vraie bête
de compet alors le mec 20 procès tout
autre chose vous avez une grande
encoches à ancrer lausanne dit
aujourd'hui une grande encoches à
l'écran incurvé cdu ole de la cdu lcd
c'est pas la même chose personnellement
c'est vrai que les mecs 20 pro est
vraiment beaucoup plus haut je trouve
que ce médecin est vraiment bien réussi
et quand on le regarde comme ça il
ressemble énormément on voit de plus ce
système ne serait ce qu'au niveau de
l'encoche au niveau du design
c'est vraiment hallucinant la vraie
différence font avoir par rapport aux
médecins pro va dire ci dessus au niveau
du doigt dans les caméras sont pas les
mêmes selon mario quelques instants mais
vous déverrouillez ici grâce au capteur
d'empreintes digitales
c'est un grand grand grand classique ç
déverrouille super bien c'est très
rapide ça vous le voyez ça saute aux
yeux par rapport aux maigres impro la
différence se situe au niveau de
l'encoche vous avez si une petite
encoche on goûte d'eau qu'est ce que
nous dit cette han coche elle nous dit
tout simplement que vous n'avez pas de
reconnaissance en trois dimensions pour
dérouler de votre visage
en gros vous avez la même chose que vous
retrouvez sur le moins de plus ce
système c'est à dire une petite encoche
en goutte d'eau ici on a un écran lcd
2244 par 1080 pixels bon sens loterie si
vous avez un écran oled qui est une plus
grosse résolution 3120 par 1140 bon
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose par
contre là où ça devient intéressant
c'est de comparer par rapport au one + 6
t parce que moins de plus ce système
reste quand même malgré tout moins cher
que le même vin aucun n'est devin carmen
décès dit à 799 et on retrouve à 599 là
par contre vous avez un écran amoled de
6,40 1 pouces las un écran lcd de 6,53
pouces 2240 par 1080 pixels 2244 par
1080 pixels
ça c'est kif kif bourricot en termes de
performance soit vous avez ce qu'il sait
mieux là vous avez lu kirin 980 ces
derniers socle de silicone qui marche
super super super bien vous avez 4 gigas
drame en termes de puissance de
performance c'est vraiment top
d'un autre côté vous avez un dragon 845
sur le wan plus système qui est couplé à
6 giga de ram en termes de pertes ce
match très très bien évoluer résultats
surtout benchmark
vous avez ici sur le mail 20 résultats
de 279 1947 est ce que sur le one + 6 t
vous avez un score de 297 1317 pourtant
le kerry 980 est donné pour être plus
performant que le cendre aegon 845
d'un côté on a 4 gigas de ram 6 giga de
ram bon ça va forcément jouer aussi gros
point positif sur le mail vin vous avez
ici la prise jack et conserver ça
franchement c'est hyper hyper hyper cool
ils sont loin de plus si c'était des
prises jack vous n'en n'avez strictement
aucune est alors encore moins sur le
mail d'un croc donc ça pour le coup
c'est vraiment bien ça veut dire que sur
1 mètre 20 pro ou ce renvoi de plus ce
système vous allez avoir uniquement des
écouteurs soit en bluetooth soit en usb
tilt c'est l'autonomie est tout
simplement excellente là dessus vous
avez une batterie de 4 mille milliards
eur franchement si vous faites pas le
sauvage si vous jouez à des jeux
tangente en train sur un usage standard
vous pouvez le garder une journée et
demie deux jours sans aucun problème la
différence avec le mec 20 pro
fondamentalement un gars n'a pas
énormément batterie peut-être les
millions terreur matri 4200 militaires
heures vous avez tous les deux un kirin
980 montfrin autonomie complètement
optimisé il marche très très très bien
et si vous comparez par rapport aux
bonnes pistes et vous avez une batterie
de trois mille sept cent millions paire
eur aud en plus si c'est pareil
une journée et demie de jours bon en
termes d'autonomie les deux sont
vraiment excellents les trois sont
vraiment excellents et là dessus je robe
absolument aucun problème en terme de
performance il a absolument rien à
envier à sa dragonne 845 screen 980
marche franchement franchement
franchement super bien j'ai absolument
aucun lag aucune latence tout va super
bien pour jouer à pib j'ai pour jouer ce
que vous voulez franchement c'est vrai
que c'est hyper hyper hyper appréciable
de la même manière au tableau
d'affichage à ça fonctionne très très
très bien dans la petite encoche à qui
l'avenir krupp et légèrement sur le côté
mais bon pour moi ça me pose absolument
aucun problème
la qualité est là franchement c'est
hyper hyper appréciable pour le
multimédia ce smartphone est vraiment
bien en termes de performances kirin 980
couplé à 4 gigas de ram
il va très très bien il sera peut-être
légèrement moins fluide qu'un médecin
promet mme may 20 franchement est au top
au niveau du fond vous avez des hauts
parleurs stéréo tout petit haut parleur
qui cachent chez lab ont pu revoir un
tout petit peu de fond c'est pas énorme
le plus gros parleur situe ici on voyait
c'est un truc il ya suffisamment de
puissance c'est pas non plus une bête de
compet mais ça marche très bien pour un
multimédia je dirais relativement
standard performances autonomie pour le
multimédia pour l'audio pour le jeu pour
la vidéo pour moi ce smartphone se
mettent 20 absolument pas à rougir de ce
point de vue là par rapport à 1020 pro
l'autonomie sensiblement similaire la
performance c'est le même socle on a un
peu plus de ram d'un côté un peu moins
de l'autre fondamentalement 4 gigas de
ram cjga drame ça va changer la face du
monde par rapport à un one + 6 t on est
sûr qu'elle j
giga de ram également il n'y a pas un
écart énorme jeu direct pour utilisation
standard ça ira parfaitement bien
maintenant à vous la différence va se
faire c'est au niveau de la photo parce
que là par contre vous avez une vraie
grosse différence entre les deux
appareils
on va commencer par le lay 20 sur le
matin vous avez un triple objectif à
l'arrière 16 mégapixels plus 12
mégapixels plus lui mégapixels le
capteur principal c'est les 12
mégapixels qui a une ouverture de f 1.8
donc bon en faible luminosité
on va voir ensuite un 16 mégapixels qui
est un maquereau grand-angle qui ouvre à
f 2.2 et on a un tel objectif de 8
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.4 qui lui va
venir pour le mode portrait et vous
permet de faire des zooms x 2 tandis que
sur le nom d'un pro vous avez une vraie
machine de guerre là dessus que vous
avez un capteur principal de 40
mégapixels ouverture de f 1.8 un
grand-angle de 20 mégapixels acquis
verture de f 2.2 et un tel objectif zoom
x 3 notes de 8 mégapixels avec
l'ouverture de f 2.4 pour moi c'est ce
point qui va réellement faire la
différence entre ces deux smartphones
alors ce qu'il faut vraiment savoir
c'est qu'avec le mail d'un projet allait
pouvoir aller très très loin au niveau
de vos photos à voir des clichés qui
sont complètement exceptionnel c'est
pour moi un des meilleur photophone de
cette année par contre par contre
franchement le mec vin ne fait pas du
tout rougir est vraiment de bonne
qualité il faut sortir vraiment des
clichés qui sont vraiment très bien et
très optimisé maintenant si on veut
comparer par rapport aux 28 system
effectivement là vous n'avez pas
triplement du photo vous avez un double
module photo capteur principal de 16
mégapixels avec une voiture de f1 points
et vous avez un deuxième capteur 2
mégapixels mme arthur de f 1.7 également
qui va travailler de concert notamment
pour le mode portrait alors les photos
elles sont vraiment très très bonne là
dessus elle fonctionne très bien qu'en
terme de photos de nuit gfr à peu près
les mêmes photos avec les deux
smartphones
vous allez voir vous dirai ce que vous
en pensez en commentaire
[Musique]
laissez-moi vous montrer ce qu'on peut
faire avec ce matin là vous êtes en
photo classique
vous avez une reconnaissance de visages
on voit très bien sa suite le visage de
mon petit personnel vous êtes sur le
capteur standard de 12 mégapixels ça
fonctionne ça fait des photos qui sont
de qualité résultat est vraiment cool
ensuite j'ai passé sur le téléobjectif
là avec le 8 méga pixels avec ouverture
de f 2.4 voyez hop c'est pareil ça
marche et lorsque je m'appuie là
j'arrive son grand angle et la voyez ça
c'est impressionnant tout de suite comme
ça ouvre g1 16 mégapixels ouverture de f
2.2 saint-simon grand temps que sur les
photos il est aussi donnée pour faire de
la macro classement approché de la tête
à fond je peux faire une photo ça marche
aussi très très bien rappelons que en
termes de navigation vous avez pas mal à
deux modes différents là dessus bon ça
va ça fonctionne c'est à 7,8 ifs
la navigation est vrai nom couleur ça
c'est lié à la surcouche seas intuitif
on peut faire pas mal de choses j'avais
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
possibilités on pas que huawei femmes
énorme boulot là dessus pour tous les
amoureux de la photo sur smartphone vous
avez énormément de possibilités
bien évidemment si vous voulez en
profiter pleinement vous avez ici le may
20 pro sur le m 23 elle faire beaucoup
plus de choses avec une qualité qui sera
franchement franchement meilleur vous
sortir une vidéo très très prochainement
de mon texte photo vidéo justement du
match d'impro donc je vous invite à vous
abonner vous verrez ça mais je trouve en
tout cas que même si ce mec vin n'est
pas la hauteur du match d'impro il a
vraiment des revenus qui sont hyper
hyper hyper hyper qualitatif
blackboulé prix photo normal là avec le
zoom x 2 est la vôtre le grand-angle en
étant exactement à la même distance
alors effectivement on va voir un petit
peu moins de couleurs avec le
grand-angle mais pour les photos en
extérieur ça fera très très très très
bien faire de mes manières de votre
portrait fonctionne très très très bien
vous avez un vrai beau détour à ce qui
est fait avec ceux qui rient 980 qui
vient vraiment le chercher dans les
moindres détails je trouve qu'il ya un
vrai beau boulot de rendu qui est fait
là dessus même lorsqu'on va complexifier
la scène comme la rajoutant un pouce en
racontant les doigts il faut vraiment
aller chercher très très très loin dans
le zouk pour commence à trouver des
défauts et encore c'est vraiment
histoire d'aller d'aller chercher la
petite bête je trouve qu'il ya un vrai
beau
boulo un vrai beau traitement logiciel
qui est fait là dessus alors vous avez
une caméra de 24 mégapixels ouverture de
f 2.2 je peux vous assurer que même les
photos sont de bonne qualité
ça fonctionne vraiment bien vous redis
une fois de plus si vous cherchez un
smartphone qui fait de bonnes photos
vous pouvez y aller sans aucun problème
si vous voulez une bête de compet font
les cent en 2020 pro mais déjà avec le
mail 20 franchement vous n'aurez mois
pour votre argent c'est un excellent
smartphone
je dirais pas de milieu de gamme je
dirais haut de gamme c'est franchement
un smartphone haut de gamme macbook pro
est un smartphone très haut de gamme
vous pouvez faire plein de choses avec
si vous aimez faire la photo vous voulez
pas dépenser beaucoup d'argent pour
aller sur un mec vins trop franchement
vous sera absolument pas déçu aux
différences que vous avez entre le mail
d'un problème est vain le mec va n'a pas
de certification ip68 là où may 20 prend
d'une certification de passation de
suite une certification d'étanchéité à
l'eau et à la poussière
néanmoins avec mike vince est toutefois
une croise une goutte d'eau vous
inquiétez pas il n'a pas prendre l'eau
doit pas se mettre à exploser à oui il y
aura absolument aucun problème
néanmoins bon il faut quand même faire
un petit peu plus attention ne vous
amusez pas au bord de l'eau au bord de
la piscine au bord de la mer ça pour
avoir des conséquences fâcheuses
autre point qui est cool vous avez aussi
du bluetooth 5.0 comme son maître un pro
comme ça que votre pucistes et là dessus
vous tombez sur un android 9 paille avec
la surcouche em 8,9
voilà après on aime ou on aime pas c'est
de la surcouche en tout cas c'est pas ça
qui va changer les performances de cette
machine bon maintenant que c'est
répondre les questions un petit peu
compliqué on a trois smartphones
on a d'un côté le may 20 on a d'un côté
le mec vaincrons on a d'un côté le moins
de plus ce système il y en a plein
d'autres
on va déjà se concentrer là dessus je
veux acheter un nouveau smartphone
lequel choisir
déjà entre le made by milk23 avec très
clair c'est une question de prix on est
à mille euros sur le médecin trop on est
un peu moins 799 qu'on peut trouver à
599 sent le mec vin très clairement à ce
prix là il ya quand même une valise si
vous recherchez pas vraiment des photos
avec du point pour un point de détail
avec un photophone qui complètement ouf
estime le mec battra franchement la
faire effectivement le médecin pro un
écran qui est beaucoup plus beau un
écran oled on va beaucoup plus loin si
vous voulez un excellent compromis pour
pouvoir les sur le maïs va déjà à mon
avis une question de budget qui va faire
vraiment la différence maintenant si
vous avez sensiblement le même budget
aux alentours des 600 euros on va se
vous avez vraiment le choix entre le web
pucistes et et le mec 20 là la question
ya peu plus compliqué parce que la
qualité de l'écran nouvelle piste et est
supérieure à celle du mec 20 même si ce
lcd et franchement maîtrisé après le
point très positif de ce matin va se
faire jeu égal en terme de photos parce
que vous avez grand-angle que vous
n'avez pas là dessus
vous allez pouvoir faire des clichés
avec le mac/val vous ne ferez pas avec
nolwenn plus système attention de one
piece east effet d'excellence photo et
si votre dada c'est plus la photo est
10ème est vraiment pouvoir faire plein
de choses avec
mieux vaut aller sur lie de vin si mes
temps voulait privilégier l'écran la
qualité de l'écran aller sur le web + 6
tc vraiment un peu la grosse différence
entre les deux parce que en termes de
performances en termes d'autonomie
les deux sont vraiment excellents la
différence je dis une fois de plus se
fera à mon avis au niveau de la photo au
niveau de l'écran ce qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui les deux usages principaux
le multimédia jeux vidéo ça c'est le
premier point donc c'est vraiment le
côté écran j'ai pu le faire tomber si le
multimédia c'est plus votre truc où
elles persistent et si maintenant la
photo c'est plus votre truc et deuxième
gros usages des smartphones notamment
pour partager sur les réseaux sociaux
allez sur le médecin et je vous le dis
si vous voulez faire des très bonnes
photos lemoine pu assister et cool je
sais je vous êtes sans vous aider vous
donne des pistes pas la solution miracle
après vous et vous la question des
surcouches est ce que vous aimez la
surcouche de huawei ski préférée celle
de oued pleuve ou réfléchissent à tout
ça en tout cas ce que je vous invite à
faire c'est à en discuter en bas en
commentaire on va essayer d'échanger là
dessus pour essayer de me guider un peu
en attendant pour faire un point final
je trouve que ce mail vin est un
excellent smartphone et je sais pas si
c'est la bonne stratégie de la part de
vendre ou de sortir mail un mec
vaincrons exactement en même temps même
s'il ya une vraie différence de prix on
voit que le mail de votre procès pour
ses larmes ultime le médecin est
franchement hyper hyper super optimisé
mais moi j'ai les deux en face de moi je
sais plus trop lequel prendre c'est un
peu compliqué une en tout cas je trouve
vraiment tous les deux excellents défaut
d'ici quelques jours on va continuer à
parler du mail 20 pro donc restez
connectés rester avec moi je vous invite
bien
moi j'ai consulté ma playlist on voir
tous les smartphones et puis et vous
faire une petite idée
par rapport à tout ça et si vous n'avez
les questions ça se passe en bas en
commentaire d'ici là soyez sages
je vous embrasse et à très bientôt ciao